pendant qu'on débatte et du sort du
dombass à paris entre le président
français le président ukrainien et la
chancelière allemande
eh bien nous sommes allés à la rencontre
des habitants de deux nièces qu afin de
leur demander ce qu'ils pensent et d'un
rapprochement entre l'ukraine et l'otan
ce qui est le souhait du président
ukrainien je vous propose d'écouter
certaines de leurs réponses cela nous
est égal nous sommes neutres des
personnes à politique nous sommes
probablement résigné vis-à-vis de la
situation
voici ce que je pense
écoutez et je sais que le temps a été
créée après la guerre pour contenir
l'influencé soviétique et on ne comprend
pas bien qu'elle est maintenant le but
de cette alliance militaire
je n'ai pas d'opinion politique pourquoi
parce que tout ce qui est fait est fait
au détriment des intérêts de la
population
tous ceux qui sont au pouvoir agissent
contre le peuple
je veux que les gens aillent bien qu'ils
aient des emplois un système de santé
une éducation surtout dans notre pays
qui est riche et maintenant les gens
sont pauvres
donc je suis contre toute influence
politique dans le donbass la situation
diffère grandement si l'on vit dans le
centre d'une grande ville comme à
donetsk où nous nous trouvons par
exemple ou ici les russes ont entretenu
les magasins sont ouverts les gens
vaquent à leurs occupations
mais par contre dès qu'on s'éloigne un
petit peu dès qu'on arrive dans ces
villages qui se trouvent au niveau de la
ligne de contact au niveau de cette
ligne de front et bien l'histoire est
complètement différente les habitants
que nous avons rencontrés hier à
l'occasion d'un reportage nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient peur peur que des
projectiles tombe dans leur jardin sur
leur maison sur leur voiture et
d'ailleurs ces dernières 24 heures les
autorités du combat sont fait savoir
qu'il y avait eu un mort à mort parmi
les civils
à la suite de bombardements du crime